contact avec jean claude van damme que
je vous incite vivement à aller voir
je repense à cette affiche pour arriver
à faire un exercice comme celui ci un
grand écart comme ça tu sais tout à
l'heure des gens sont venus me voir en
me disant c'est un montage c'est truqué
c'est pas vrai ou alors faut deux heures
d'échauffement tu peux nous prouver le
contraire
le problème mais des gens que je me suis
beaucoup entraîné pour ça ça vient pas
tout seul et je conseille aux jeunes
s'ils veulent faire le grand écart pour
des sports comme comme le karaté par
exemple de commencer très jeune vers 11
ans je crois que tu as commencé les
choses véritablement sérieusement vers
11-12 ans way qui peut nous faire un
petit quelque chose là qu'on puisse se
rendre compte du tu peux reproduire le
dessin de cette affiche mais je vais te
montrer quelques techniques de travail
que je fais donc pour les films pour
pouvoir contrôler mes mouvements
oui en même temps pour acquérir donc de
la puissance et de la vitesse
mais apple sera de chine et je vais te
prendre comme partenaire - roule là
c'était pas prévu du tout ça mais pas du
tout prévu est ce que quelqu'un veut
venir à ma place pas de volontaires qui
aura bien moins bon on va s'amuser alors
on ne bouge pas normalement ça se fait
avec partenaires bon on se tient la main
c'est un mouvement donc de stretching
dextérité et je travaille sur trois
niveaux
là je travaille au niveau bas lentement
slow motion niveau milieu là et puis
niveau là et je reste à mon aise le
soleil fait chaud super et alors et les
mouvements qui sont plus rapides comme
ceux ci ne bouge pas
j'ai senti le vent ou encore un autre ne
bouge pas et que nicolas est alors le
grand écart
voilà pour cela pensez que c'était une
photo truquée tout ça est formellement
démenti dis-moi jean-claude une petite
chose j'ai toujours été et tous les
passionnés de cinéma se demande dans les
films d'action
jusqu'où peuvent aller les comédiens en
s'investissant vraiment dans les
séquences un peu dangereuse y at-il une
limite aux choses raisonnables mais
disons qu'il faut bien choisir son casté
pour ce film si on a fait appel à des
très bons combattants
en même temps acteurs par exemple le
combat final dans ce film a été fait
avec abdel qu'ils y est un garçon de
belgique qui est très puissant mais qui
s'est construit de ses coups de poing et
coups de pied tout ça il y avait une
entente parfait pour s'est jamais blessé
mais parfois et les accidents qui
arrivent il faut dire que vous avez vu
predator avec un hall 3 n est guère oui
vous souvenez de ce lui monstres
extraterrestres qu'on voit à la fin
c'était jean claude le monstres
extraterrestres c'était jean claude une
petite anecdote sur le tournage avant de
nous quitter
justement en parlant de de cascades
le monstre du prédateur est a été plus
ou moins bien fait et ils m'ont demandé
de sauter donc d'un obstacle et je
savais que physiquement c'est impossible
alors ils ont pris un stand mène un
cascadeur professionnel américain il
faut pardonner mon français est il a
fait donc la casca laisser casser les
chevilles on a dû arrêter le tournage
pendant plusieurs semaines et on a fait
donc un autre costume et moi j'ai
commencé ma route vers blood sports
riglos peur d'user à brens et tout ça
t'a porté bonheur croisons les doigts
pour toi jean claude van damme à la
conquête d'hollywood et en attendant
d'en savoir plus
full contact n'oubliez pas un des grands
films d'action de cet été 1990 merci
jean claude et à très bientôt au journal
jean charles pauze embrasse la séquence
suivante ça s'appelle playback si je le
retrouve dans un instant avec les quatre
candidats restez avec nous surtout